tres semanas después de un nuevo
gobierno los peruanos se hacen sentir
cientos de trabajadores agrícolas
bloquearon la carretera panamericana
cerca de la ciudad de pisco al norte de
la capital lima ellos piden mejores
salarios y condiciones laborales en su
sector estamos cansados de la tanta
explotación tanta injusticia el paro
agrario inició el lunes y la fila de
vehículos ya se extiende
no hay nada
la policía ha intentado combatir a los
manifestantes y se reportó al menos un
muerto en las últimas horas un saldo que
el gobierno intenta controlar si estamos
haciendo lo posible por mantener el
orden público de una manera sin violar
derechos humanos sin crear problemas
adicionales en su mayoría trabajan en
viñedos aledaños de pisco la bebida
emblemática de perú el salario a menudo
no supera los 10 dólares por jornadas de
trabajo de hasta 14 horas de acuerdo con
los manifestantes las protestas
continuarían esperan que el nuevo
gobierno interceda por ellos